it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to
see the devil uncle Joey here wishing
you a beautiful [ __ ] Wednesday
may you avoid [ __ ] drama and may you
accomplish all the [ __ ] goals you had
today
now [ __ ] that [ __ ] his uncle Joey here
coming at you stronger than debt -
feeling good looking good Billy Ray it's
Black History Month you understand me
you got active [ __ ] correctly it's a
beautiful day we're here we got some
tremendous weed today we got the [ __ ]
Private Reserve from perennial don't
forget I got a [ __ ] container of that
[ __ ] that killed [ __ ] what's-his-name
the other day I got a little bit over
here for us to smoke but besides that -
listen you're not doing nothing today go
to perenial forget that 24 sativa you're
gonna call me back we'll go Joey
how much do I [ __ ] love you but
enough is enough with the chitchat let's
smoke a bowl and let's see what the [ __ ]
where the day takes us you understand
in correction not with a date Texas
where we take this [ __ ] day
because we're the captain kirk's are on
enterprise understand me a lot of people
look at when you wake up in the morning
so there's somebody have a good day you
don't know what the [ __ ] going on
in your mind you're having a [ __ ]
great day that's it no flat tires nobody
cutting you off no [ __ ] bills nobody
toes your [ __ ] car it's but it all
starts in your [ __ ] mind in this damn
you wake up you say you know what today
the day is gonna suck my dick I'm
smacking the [ __ ] out of this
[ __ ] today and the next thing
you know you had a good [ __ ] dare you
smoke some weed
you can't bestow your [ __ ] goes you
got a nice lunch who's better than
[ __ ] you mmm but if you ain't blowing
those smokes on the [ __ ] Wednesday
you're not starting off on the right
foot you understand me I already have my
able to protein shake I took my daughter
to school I did a little [ __ ] writing
now it's time to [ __ ] spark this
[ __ ] get focused and take down
his [ __ ] day you understand me I was
strong the other night with the acid and
we're doing it again tonight if you're
not doing that stop by the church 7:00
p.m. we're gonna rock again till I got
the sugar cubes I got the big [ __ ]
container reefer and that's it that's it
and that's that you understand me
at least you got something to look
forward to in case get them people hit
me up Patel you should do mushrooms Joey
you should do this and listen I only
[ __ ] with the SID
that killed the double that VM tell that
[ __ ] kid [ __ ] I don't [ __ ] with that
[ __ ] you want to see the devil and get
the answer to your [ __ ] questions you
come on over and you pop one of those
[ __ ] sugar cubes you'll get all the
answers you need I'm gonna sit there
smoke the damn T I'm 13 again I'm gonna
get a hat with a propeller get the [ __ ]
out of it if we're gonna go in you're
gonna go in in this damn it
I've been doing the real sig since the
[ __ ] late seventies windowpane blada
microdot [ __ ] double-barrel sunshine
you know I don't have time for [ __ ]
kids Shep they gonna hat with a
propeller the [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
Angela I'm going to France tit I'm gonna
do some how you askin suck my dick you
wanna get the [ __ ] you want to see
the devil move to the Bronx I'm gonna
$10 bag of the Chinese H and then come
back to me for up you and your ayahuasca
and all this [ __ ] that these Gentiles
are gonna be cool I'll take you to the
[ __ ] who put that I'll show you a
devil with horns which smoke coming out
of his ears
that'll stop you from eating or doing
drugs or whatever the [ __ ] you guys are
gonna do it that's a little [ __ ] [ __ ]
to come impress people huh I don't smoke
pot no more [ __ ] little white [ __ ]
brilliant all that [ __ ] I don't buy it
another that [ __ ] okay this is the
[ __ ] answer you want to see the devil
I figure the Bronx and get you $7 bag a
Chinese number - you'll see get the [ __ ]
out of my face oh you don't [ __ ] [ __ ] I
think to be [ __ ] different to be cool
so a bunch of [ __ ] little young kids
I'm impressed with you huh oh really
you went down hill Cooley they bathe you
in my face
I ran with Bucky Gillis you do a [ __ ]
little $3.00 head or some [ __ ] you'll
see what the [ __ ] happens to you I'm
gonna be running with these real [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ] I did DMT [ __ ] out
of my face come on over and do this lick
what I got and see what happens to you
you [ __ ] punks
[ __ ] tremendous tremendous this is
all your knee right all out of this [ __ ]
it's like these idiots that put filters
on the [ __ ] I'm the [ __ ] joints
that listen I've seen it all take that
[ __ ] down all your buddies that believes
and all that [ __ ] so you could sit
around and oh my god [ __ ] jungle
preach
give me a [ __ ] break all right all
these little kids get impressed with you
want to impress me go to Bronx at doing
the morning get a [ __ ] to $7 back that
that's how you impress me everybody else
could suck my dick playing his sympathy
you know I [ __ ] and saved from the
whole idea I don't give a [ __ ] about
another these [ __ ] that's why
I'm here solo in the morning that he
would eat people you know taking
pictures and the [ __ ]
guys have been [ __ ] brainwashed and
to be a little [ __ ] that oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] my face now I want to smoke this
[ __ ] that's silenced [ __ ] Dean Delray
understand me Dean that way they'd have
to go to [ __ ] it [ __ ] hard contain the
jungles you see how he saw that that
will the ED they're right in front of
you [ __ ] what's the [ __ ]
putt get it changed his whole life right
there he didn't have to go huh
I'll meet my friends turn into the
jungle okay that's great dump them my
mother [ __ ] jungle score my seat off
to my mother [ __ ] jungle [ __ ]
I'm sweating from this wheat and you
want to go to the jungle you [ __ ]
Momo's the answers right there that's
that's it right there
all these huh well well Stephen will
ever said to you hey the mushrooms the
[ __ ] you reading books about mushrooms I
live it [ __ ] I read a book about
the Emperor is something the Emperor
that sucked my dick and so can you
little [ __ ] that I fall for
should go read your [ __ ] High Times
and get impressed
get your little hat with the port and
propeller if you gonna go deep you go
deep with uncle Joey you're not going
out with these other [ __ ] morons and
you get impressed with their [ __ ]
face [ __ ]
look at that I need to go to a jungle I
need to hang out with [ __ ] a guru
that's it that's that don't forget
churchill what's happened now tonight
and [ __ ] at seven o'clock okay
on top of that a new CD comes out Friday
on [ __ ] I don't go preorder for me
hook me up and [ __ ] and we'll [ __ ] do
what we need to do it right
I'm spawned I'm feeling good it's a
beautiful [ __ ] day and somebody is
gonna suck it dick maybe not this
afternoon maybe not tonight some land a
[ __ ] bag somewhere in the night if
you stay positive everything's gonna
work out of him
look at that there's 98 with our [ __ ]
doing drugs or [ __ ] around with these
[ __ ] junkies I was running with in
those 10 years you see a lot of [ __ ]
late
you see what works you see what [ __ ]
you see what the trends are to be cool
and if you look at me I never tried to
be [ __ ] cool I'm a bad [ __ ]
since I came out of my mom's [ __ ]
snatch she understand me
there's none here to try to be cool what
I'm designer jeans on
note that goes I need none to impression
or impresses you my dick my heart and my
balls okay that's the only thing I got
to impress [ __ ] anybody all right so
put back your [ __ ] pipe and smoke it
write your goals do your push-ups and
stop falling for these [ __ ] jerk-offs
okay you sit there he's so cool the [ __ ]
out of my face you know cool is you
[ __ ] don't buy into that [ __ ]
smoke your weed eat your [ __ ] it's
oatmeal and that's it right your [ __ ]
calls and that's all the only reason I
got nothing I'm not even a funny [ __ ]
dude
the reason why you watch this just cuz
you know I got heart and balls I don't
give a [ __ ] I don't think none of nobody
never I don't have time for that [ __ ] I
don't buy into know this fake hype you
[ __ ] [ __ ] buy into out there
protesting and [ __ ] the only hype I buy
into the hype in my heart you understand
me the [ __ ] people around me and the
people are close to me so I don't give a
[ __ ] about the rest of that [ __ ] just
suck your dick and I suggest you do the
same okay
stay black I'll be back on the church
tonight seven o'clock ready if [ __ ]
rock we got some sugar cubes we got
everything
okay and that's all you need to know you
know I never [ __ ] lie to you
[ __ ] on what I do you do that's
how we do it all right
stay black I don't do nothin to try to
impress your mother look at look at me
the [ __ ]
stay black stay solid and don't believe
the [ __ ] Heitmann they could off suck
your dick at the end of the day
stay black I love you a [ __ ] stone
Jack